bonsoir à toutes et tous je voulais
commencer par vous parler d'un problème
que j'ai eu hier soir et qui concerne
aussi 30% de la population française les
insomnies je fais des insomnies depuis
des années j'ai quasi tout essayer
absolument rien ne fonctionne dans ces
cas là j'ai juste une seule solution les
reportages historique
j'adore l'histoire elle me passionne
elle me berce et parfois elle m'aide à
m'endormir
vous l'aurez compris je suis pas venu
pour vous parler des problèmes de
sommeil ou de ma passion pour les
reportages du service public mais bien
vous vous parler d'histoire et en
particulier de celle des femmes
une histoire souvent méconnus pour ne
pas dire invisible pour ne pas dire
complètement caché ce que j'ai ressenti
lorsque j'ai découvert cette histoire
c'est de la trahison
je me suis rendu compte qu'on m'avait
menti qu'on m'avait caché toute une
partie de la construction de nos
sociétés qu'on avait raconté une autre
version des faits et je me suis rendu
compte de l'impact que ces fausses
croyances avait sur les relations femmes
hommes
pour illustrer mon propos je vais
prendre un exemple très populaire qu'a
priori tout le monde connaît jésus je
sais je touche à la religion c'est un
petit peu délicat mais je tenais
vraiment à prendre cet exemple vieux de
2000 ans pour vous montrer comment il
conditionne encore la représentation
qu'on a des femmes aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler plus précisément de ce qu'on
appelle le syndrome de la maman et la
il ya deux femmes principal dans
l'histoire de jésus
la maire marie vierge évidemment symbole
de pureté et de dévotion et la
marie madeleine pêcheresse repentie
qu'ils tournaient un petit peu trop
autour de jésus
deux femmes et deux types de femmes
seulement
et c'est ça le syndrome de la maman et
la c'est cette dichotomie que
l'on a créé autour de l'image des femmes
et que deux possibilités on est soit une
fille bien soit une traînée
avoir une sexualité débordante mais que
dans son couple sinon les une
faut mettre des jupes pour rester
féminine mais pas trop courte il ya
quelques temps secrets d'histoire à
l'ombre d'un doute ont sorti un
reportage sur jésus une version
historique des faits par religieuse j ai
appris que marie lorsqu'elle a accouché
de jésus elle avait 16 ans que joseph
était un vieillard de 70 ans qu'il avait
recueillie et mise enceinte on précise
d'ailleurs passé le rapport était
consenti
mais comme il n'était pas marié avec une
prophétie annonçait une essence divine à
venir marie s'est retrouvée mise
enceinte par un ange
quant à marie madeleine son histoire est
en réalité une agrégation de différents
personnages
à la base elle était juste célibataire
mais c'était signe de mauvaise vie à
l'époque et ça l'est toujours un peu
d'ailleurs une femme célibataire c'est
suspect pour certains il aurait même pu
être la femme de jésus alors voilà
comment une histoire faussement raconté
il ya plus de 2000 ans conditionne
toujours l'image que l'on a des femmes
et des exemples comme ça il y en a plein
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen on nous a jamais vraiment
préciser que quand elle a été écrite
elle ne concernait que les hommes pas
l'homme soit disant avec un grand h pas
les droits humains comme il faudrait
dire juste les hommes on nous a jamais
parlé d'olympe de gouges qui a été
guillotiné pour avoir écrit la
déclaration de la femme et de la
citoyenne
le code civil qui est à la base de notre
république encore aujourd'hui on nous a
jamais mentionné qu'il a été un immense
retour en arrière pour les femmes qui
ont été mises sous tutelle de leur mari
est considéré comme mineur c'est à dire
qu'elle avait autant de droits que des
enfants le travail des femmes les femmes
ont toujours travaillé depuis la nuit
des temps mais on nous a vendu ce modèle
bourgeois du père providentiel qui
ramène l'argent à la maison et qui
subvient aux besoins de la famille ce
que je veux vous montrer c'est que ces
inégalités que l'on croit naturel
biologique
oh mon préféré est venue de mars et de
vénus sont en réalité des constructions
sociales millénaire et surtout des
récits qui ont été racontée de manière
biaisée
ce n'est qu'une histoire de
représentation d'image de discours de ce
que l'on raconte
il aura fallu le travail incroyable
d'historienne comme michelle perrot
christine bard ou dans un autre registre
pénélope bagieu ou aux gones goubert
pour réécrire l'histoire des femmes les
raconter autrement et les rendre
visibles
soyons critique vis-à-vis de notre
histoire
d'autant qu'on nous l'a appris quand
nous étions enfants et on nous l'a
appris comme des faits comme on nous
apprend que un plus un font d'eux donc
forcément on se pose pas la question
mais notre rôle en tant qu'adulte c'est
de remettre en perspective cette
histoire se rendre compte qu'elle a été
écrite raconté interprété avec un seul
point de vue alors ne vous méprenez pas
je suis pas du tout en train de vous
dire de tout remettre en question et de
céder à des théories du complot un petit
peu douteuse simplement de ne pas rester
naïf non pas parce que cette histoire
est fausse mais parce que nous n'en
connaissons qu'une seule partie le
danger d'une histoire unique
c'était d'ailleurs le premier tadic ce
de schémas mandat ngozi adichie la
méconnaissance dans laquelle on reste
quand on se contente que d'une seule
version de l'histoire comme les
histoires peuvent être utilisées à
mauvais escient
la question à se poser maintenant c'est
où sont celles dont on ne parle jamais
et pourquoi est ce qu'on n'en parle
jamais est ce que vous connaissez les
faits mathilda c'est un concept qui a
été découvert par l'historienne margaret
rossiter l'effet matilda c'est la
minimisation voire le déni quasi
systémique de la contribution des femmes
scientifiques à la recherche parce que
leurs travaux sont
quasi-systématiquement réattribué à
leurs collègues masculins
rosaline franklyn qui a pris la première
photographie de l'adn margaret gauthier
qui a découvert la trisomie 21 ou encore
miley veinstein la femme d'albert qui a
participé à la moitié des recherches de
son mari jocelyne bell qui a découvert
le premier pulsar toutes ont été
dépossédés de leurs découvertes et se
sont même fait voler des prix nobel
et pendant ce temps là on continue de
déplorer l'absence des femmes dans les
sciences et c'est vrai qu'en france dans
un secteur aussi porteur que le digital
il n'y a que 27 % de femmes
alors qu'il est encore 30 ans le
numérique était majoritairement féminin
mais dès qu'il ya eu un intérêt
économique les hommes se sont ré emparée
du secteur et on a créé cette culture
geek qui consiste encore souvent à
représenter des sommes à la puberté un
peu tardive en train de coder dans des
caves
je le répète ce n'est qu'une histoire de
représentation d'image de discours de ce
que l'on raconte
parce que pour ramener les femmes dans
le numérique on sait ce qu'il faut faire
sensibiliser les jeunes filles montré
des role models mettre en place des best
practice mettre en place des soldes des
formations et surtout arrêter de
considérer qu'il existe des métiers de
filles et des métiers de garçons on les
a les solutions
la question c'est quand est-ce qu'on se
donne réellement les moyens de mettre en
place et qui pour s'y engager
concrètement alors la bonne nouvelle
c'est que les femmes reprennent de plus
en plus le pouvoir sur leurs récits on
compte encore très peu de réaliser trice
de films de romancière d'écrivaine mais
elles ont de plus en plus d'outils entre
leurs mains pour raconter leur version
des faits encore faut-il qu'on les
écoute et qu'on les croit regardons
rapidement notre histoire contemporaine
celle qu'on est en train d'écrire et
qu'on va laisser dans les livres on n'a
pas connu d'événement aussi majeure que
des guerres mondiales récemment donc de
quoi allons nous parler de terrorisme de
deux chefs d'état un petit peu
particulier qui se menacent avec des
tweets de la nouvelle montée des
extrêmes de ce nouveau monde qu'on
essaie de construire alors qu'il peut
s'effondrer du jour au lendemain de la
crise écologique sur laquelle personne
ne se bouge non plus et qu'est ce qu'on
va raconter des relations femmes hommes
nous sommes potentiellement à l'aube
d'une quatrième vague féministe
en réalité on n'a jamais été si proche
d'une vraie révolution sur ces sujets en
même temps si proche d'un immense retour
en arrière on est à l'aube de
changements majeurs avec en parallèle
une montée des mouvements masculinistes
de plus en plus puissants et c'est le
sens de l'histoire
dès qu'il ya des mouvements pour tirer
dans le sens du progrès y en a forcément
pour tirer dans l'autre sens mais si
j'ai appris quelque chose sur l'histoire
c'est qu'elle est très très loin d'être
progressiste et en soit c'est vrai
regardez on n'est même plus capable de
savoir comment est ce qu'on a construit
les pyramides où il se passe quelque
chose sur l'égalité mais c'est
extrêmement fragile
projetons nous d'ailleurs dont le futur
qu'on est en train de dessiner on est
déjà en train de créer des intelligences
artificielles racistes et sexistes
comment est ce possible l'on continue de
reproduire ces mêmes schémas
on va vraiment laissé le monde de demain
être pensée développée gouverner
uniquement par des hommes blancs on
laisse faire on continue de perpétrer
cette vision unique de notre histoire où
est ce qu'on prend la mesure de l'impact
de nos choix et on agit pour commencer à
créer un monde plus inclusif le futur
s'écrit maintenant reste à savoir quel
futur nous souhaitons et qui pour le
construire en écrivant ce tête j'avais
l'immense ambition de vous apporter de
nouvelles solutions mais je me suis
rendu compte que j'allais rien
réinventer parce qu'en réalité les
solutions les existe déjà elle existe
déjà mais le sujet d'égalité femmes
hommes est un sujet compliqué tout le
monde a un avis sur la question
tout le monde se sent concerné et
surtout légitime à en débattre
par le simple fait d'être une femme ou
un homme ou autre d'ailleurs
mais ce qu'il faut réaliser c'est que
votre rapport à l'égalité femmes-hommes
il est conditionné par vos croyances par
votre histoire personnelle et ce qui
conditionne encore les progrès d'égalité
femmes hommes ce qui fait qu'on n'arrive
toujours pas à mettre en place des
solutions c'est notre capacité à
remettre en question ses croyances pour
que les solutions marche il va falloir
que chacun et chacune d'entre nous
déconstruisent ce qu'il croit être vrai
une représentation nos images ce qu'on
nous a raconté
j'ai réalisé que mon rôle n'était pas de
venir semer de nouvelles graines sur le
terreau de l'égalité mais plutôt
d'arroser des plantes existante est de
vous proposer qu'on les fasse pousser
ensemble
pour cela il va falloir sortir de nos
individualités de nos petites vérités
regarder les faits tels qu'ils sont pour
passer à l'action ensemble au même
niveau
est ce qu'on est prêt à renoncer à nos
perceptions et à nos enjeux personnels
au nom de nos idéaux communs est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à le faire avant de
partir je voulais quand même vous
laisser avec une piste que je suis
encore une fois les chercher dans un
reportage historique sur andré malraux
est heureux hasard il se trouve qu'on
est dans une salle aujourd'hui qui porte
son nom
notre reportage il évoquait déjà la
perte de sens de nos sociétés modernes
où va-t-on que fait-on à quoi sert tôt
il pensait que notre monde était en fin
de cycle que le monde occidental aller
vers une impasse qu'il avait perdu le
sens de son existence depuis qu'il avait
tué ses croyances pour lui une
civilisation ne peut se passer de valeur
suprême et de spiritualité des valeurs
suprêmes à notre société moi j'en vois
pourtant 3 écrites sur les frontons de
chacune de nos écoles de nos mairies de
nos monuments et l'une d'entre elles
c'est l'égalité c'est une belle valeur à
laquelle croire non surtout en ce moment
et si c'était cette histoire qu'on
écrivait cette empreinte qu'on pourrait
les c est ce qu on pourrait être la
première génération qui fera aboutir
l'égalité est ce que le stéphane bern du
futur racontera qu'en 2019 lors d'un
tête x à lyon 200 personnes ont osé se
remettre en question et on commençait
une petite révolution intérieure sur ce
qu'elle pensait être vrai pour croire en
demain écrire son histoire
il va falloir accepter de remettre en
question ce que l'on sait accepter de ne
pas tout savoir prendre conscience qu'il
manque une partie de notre passé et se
réconcilier avec ce passé et avec tous
nos autres passé plus ou moins difficile
d'ailleurs
pour envisager le futur en naissant
cette fois ci personne sur le côté et
j'espère très sincèrement que ça nous
permettra de dormir un petit peu mieux
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]